Wow and these get worse from your Oh God
yeah Mad Dog and Megadeth sauce hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot one it's the show with hot questions
even hotter wings and today I'm joined
by Andy Cohen you know him it's the face
of Bravo and you can catch him still in
t five nights a week and watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen
you're also host love connection
premiering May 25th on Fox Andy welcome
to the show how you doing good how are
you
scarce you know what a lot of clubs come
in with that kind of attitude
are you with hot food poor fat people
wouldn't st. Louis like you know there's
a lot of barbeque in st. Louis I mean
but not you and never even no no well
are you ready to just get it go are ya
[Music]
that's good you like it ya like it no
big deal
watch what happens live yes show that I
don't think it's enough credit for pay
want to do a few shows that goes there
plus it's live so it can kind of fly off
the rails at a time rue is the last
celebrity that gave you the pay you're
not supposed to ask me that question
face oh wow oh wow um who gave me that
face last you know what the worst thing
about doing a show every night is you
forget and I smoked a lot of pot say
maybe that's the wrong thing I did not
doing a show every night it makes you
forget the people it's that I struggle
out of hot and do shows every night you
know what Iommi wants I think she was
just scared of me and she was on with
Susan Sarandon who will say anything and
it's like the perfect gas she was kind
of looking at me scared the whole time
if the watch it happens live set on fire
you can only save one chachki oh wow I
think we saved the shot ski that Jimmy
Fallon gave me or Lady Gaga's P which we
turned into perfume which has become
kind of a cultural you know thing also
you can drink on your show would you had
a nice touch have you ever had to cut
anyone off no I I would like them to
keep going I would never cut them off
get drunker puke if you need to have you
anybody puke um there was someone from
SNL on who brought their plus-one I
think it was someone they were dating
cubed in the audience like during a
commercial break oh no amazing we've had
a couple guest view yeah oh really
yeah no cuz I'm kind of a puke
[Music]
easy peasy Tabasco I got this alright
now it's kicking in alright
as you detail in your books you're a guy
who's on the scene lots of famous
friends always on the red carpet which
one of your famous buddies throws the
best house party
they throw different kinds I'm going to
say Anderson Cooper when my first book
came out he threw me a book party and it
was a rager people were like this is a
book party I'm like yeah this is a good
party like it's gonna go until 4:00
isn't that what happens in fun parties
and then I know that you're a guy who
will seize the moment
yeah can you think of a time where you
ran up on somebody that you wanted to
befriend and because of an awkward joke
or for whatever reason I'll flat on your
face I remember the NBC up front last
year I I introduced myself to this girl
who I thought was a telenovela star she
had big black hair and she goes I'm
Vanessa Hudgens I was on your show last
week like oh my god your hair is
different I'm so sorry
[Music]
just so you know my mouth is burning a
little bit yeah well I just want
everyone to know what's happening one of
the biggest mistakes reality TV stars
make when they experience overnight
celebrity oh wow what a good question um
don't be like oh this is my new life I'm
a superstar this is gonna last forever
because it's not I would say keep your
day job if you're on a reality show
don't be a dick because you could start
the season and everyone's like oh my god
you're so fierce you're amazing dinner
Netta and then what they don't realize
is you're going to say something really
racist against some minority group in
episode 8 yeah yeah and then everyone is
going to turn on you horribly and you're
like wait a minute though I was like
it's called a story arc totally you know
when you think about these songs that
come out Housewives whether it's Google
me or with the what's the good one money
can't buy you class very good which
one's your favorite you know what I
always go back to the first and the
classic which was don't be tardy for the
party they do have a special place in my
heart for money
FIU class and she say lovey which are of
course the countess's jams melissa gorga
had a couple song on display was really
good I know them all you know they're
the soundtrack of my life this is really
good radda habanero and black coffee I
really like this one so I want to talk
to you about weed for a second so
they're not shy about the topic yeah
it's smoking with Snoop Dogg the
best-in-show experience that he'd
expected to beer with little
disappointing no it was great it was
after the show and we went back in his
dressing room and he lit up and then he
passed it to me and I you know I like a
big head and his manager goes okay you
need to stop right there like don't take
any more rap weed is different right
than regular yeah then Andy Jewish
voices say who is sweet and it was a
creeper it kind of like these wings um
it kind of you know I he was pitching me
a show I took the pitch and then like
ten minutes later I was like and I had
to go do a work thing which was terrible
it was during the day but I've also
gotten high with Willie Nelson oh how
was that - it was great um it was really
cool I was at a party and I was like oh
my god I'm getting high with Willie
Nelson so that was very cool we ever had
any like bad edibles experiences or
anything like that um no I got mainly
good edible experience I loved achieve
achoo I loved a lolly those lollies got
like through my first second first and
second book tour you know what I
disliked as much as spicy food but milk
actually this milk is very cold which is
the way to drink it yeah I don't love no
it's kind of sweet maybe I do like it I
actually have a recurring segment on our
show called explain that Graham and what
we do is we do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram before interesting pictures
that need more context I'll show you the
picture and then you just tell me the
bigger story does that sound good yes
anymore how you doing so far good my
mouse is hot I want a long tongue
contest in Miami once you did whoa all
right gene Simmons look at happening
yeah yeah
here you are was 50-cent yeah on set
that was an iconic moment on the show
because someone called in to the show
and asked pity
how much cash he had in his pocket this
was not planned this was not set up he
had ten grand in his pocket was amazing
Vivica Fox then came on and accused him
of being a booty snatcher which made a
gay guy so that was crazy and that
immediately was like trending on Twitter
crazy crazy and then he came on and he
was on with Leah Remini we got in a long
discussion about getting your ass eaten
which he said he enjoys and we talked
about that there's some young MKX selfie
with kim k that was actually on the day
she left I was interviewing her in front
of an audience and some of that and she
was leaving to go to Paris that day and
three days later she was robbed at
gunpoint and that security guard who was
with her that day I think his name was
Moscow's she want him firing him like he
was I don't know I have been asking her
about that ring which wound up getting
stolen and so crazy and then last one
that is a picture of Madonna and I at a
premiere of this Tom Ford movie I can't
remember how it happened but believe it
or not she called me and asked me if I
would be her date to this movie premiere
and I go over to her place and this
other guy showed up who I guess she had
also wanted to be her date so it was me
and her and this kind of hot model we
were waiting for her in her living room
she lived on the Upper West Side at the
time and she came down and then we went
and she has this car with like sirens on
it we might have had
I'm sort of an escort it was crazy and I
was like illegal I think like you're not
the mayor like am I not unlike you you
are Kendra Donna and of course we
famously fought that night you did yeah
you did not feel but I wanted to [ __ ]
the model okay this looks veiny which I
don't like it and I don't like something
called ghost pepper makes me scared it's
a blue bling lots to contend with over
here this is going to be a creeper right
now yep oh so reality TV is kind of like
rap music and that it's sometimes hard
to explain to your mom why you love it
so much and then that seems to have only
got the work less than the ghost pepper
go on for somebody who has these sorts
of dinner conversation what's the smart
Andy Cohen way of unpackaging the pros
and cons of reality TV and its impact I
don't like it that it they're all
clumped together and it's like oh did
reality kill this person and did this
that they're all different I mean
American Idol is different from the
Amazing Race is different from the
Housewives
I think the outsides have replaced the
soap opera it's the modern soap opera
for our generation for our time and
truth is stranger than fiction and it's
meant to be entertaining if you don't
like it there's certainly 8,000 other
things you can watch on TV one um be
apocalypse uh-huh okay you seem like
you're having a worse time than I am so
here's that you know what people don't
appreciate Andy is I got to do this week
over week it's like the post office you
know like rain sleet snow and you know
that if somebody you have to do it now
yo yo yo bad it's what you're doing I'm
not getting paid to do is show you are
so who do you feel bad
[Music]
Wow it's a crazy one Oh God
yep there it is Andy and then there's no
clothes but I think I want the milk to
get rid of this this is like a Sophie's
Choice so when we had Michael Rapaport
on the show he bless his reality TV show
top five and I've actually dabbled in
the Bravo brand quite a bit great so I
want to almost show do you watch
Vanderpump rules I'm a big filtration
guy yeah that's a good straight gun
actually - I'm a little more housewives
Eve oh good so I want to bounce some of
my favorite Bravo liberties off of you
okay I just want to get your snap take
Kenya from Atlanta okay
you sound like you're suffering Kenyon's
I do a little bit um Kenya I think is
super smart she's very smart I am
fascinated with whether her boobs are
real she says they are should not be
underestimated
how about James from Vanderpump rules
James is hilarious I root for James he
got furious at me two seasons ago at
that reunion for not um talking more
about pump sessions his CD which is
hilarious Jax from Vanderpump rules Jax
um season one was really hot then he
kind of bulked up a little bit has he
ever done it with a guy I don't know he
seems like he might be a hole as a whole
kind of guy he does anyway are we
allowed to chew a little gum you can do
whatever you want anyone sure that oh
hell oh yeah more much really no I don't
think a mental help you really I think
it makes things slightly worse Oh No
Teresa Giudice
Teresa is hilarious Teresa and I when
she was confined she and I were emailing
into email with a prisoner you have to
like go on the special website and put
in your social security number and all
this stuff every email I got from her
said in the subject line it's Teresa I'm
like I know I'm not corresponding with
any other prisoners in this facility
like I know
whoo this is my mouth is burning machine
it happens on the show every once in a
while I don't know why I blow ideal why
so this is the bomb okay oh boy
medium knew you were gonna like that one
Wow and these got worse from here Oh God
yeah Mad Dog and Megadeth sauce so there
are legions of fans that are obsessed
with this Andy Cohen Anderson Cooper bro
man yeah what's Anderson Cooper's most
annoying travel habits he is moody I can
read his moods really really well we've
been friends for 25 years how my lips
have this [ __ ] on it nah really nowhere
to go yeah we have yeah stuck on this
show when you guys take there's like a
wave hitting me now yeah we're down
Liris is it kind of is like Molly
there's like a wave I've actually come
to kind of enjoy that high a little bit
really
you have to otherwise we're Mike I don't
like what's happening to my lips
yeah first to try this movie and he
isn't working out for you no I'm trying
to get it off my lips Wow when you guys
take the gym selfies what are those
workouts look like because you're both
pretty yoke um our tour promoter has
made these graphics of us that are so
bad that we're like we'll just post like
a picture of us in the gym and then
I can't believe we're producing more you
said that the stage show you and
Anderson is kind of like a night out
drinking with you guys yeah
what doesn't make the stage everything
makes it people have asked me are you a
top or a bottom people are asking like
how big is your dick are you top or a
bottom top so it feels better when I
breathe in yeah you kind of get that uh
you get a little little instant relief
little breeze action okay this is mad
dog 357 now I'm worried about getting it
all right well yeah I noticed you have a
very unique style of eating don't like
that I know that right now it seems like
you're stuck in this hole and you're
never going to get out does get better
your day low and unsubdued it yeah
different that gala tonight
I'm not going okay that's good okay tell
me about it that would have been bad
planning I'm going to do hot ones then
go to the Met Gala you rep your st.
Louis roots on the show whether it's a
Cardinals onesie or what have you so I
want to talk to you about the Gateway to
the West for a second what's the dish
that you can get in st. Louis that you
can't get in New York City that you
missed toasted ravioli um which is like
deep fried ravioli that you dipped in
marinara sauce that would taste really
good right now
and provel cheese pizza it's disgusting
it's like white trash cheese I think I
don't even know if it's real cheese I
grew up on it so it's an acquired taste
to make it on really super thin crossed
pizzas or called st. louis-style pizza
but they're I think they would be gross
to normal people all right Andy Cohen
what are you doing why are you doing
that
are you putting that on my way so so you
don't have to I'm not here's the
situation it's tradition around here to
dab the last wing you don't have to if
you don't want I don't
that's that I'm like my list I'm burning
off I do though because the other rap
girl do you know a lot of bravado yeah
it was Michael Rapaport so he gets in
here he's talking a big game yeah he's
mad at us for the front half for not
making the wings hot enough he's
chucking wings around the Judeo he's
rocking out the side of his mouth but
then he had one of the more classic
meltdowns that we've ever had in series
history he had a real hard time with
these last couple yeah as you can relate
it would seem Andy all right
you don't have to dab but you do have to
take a bite well I don't anytime you
have to I feel like a being coming
really grow like a minute Sam storm
you're in a sandstorm and have one more
question for you Andy Kahn while you're
dying on Blairs Megadeth sauce with
liquid range I'd like to play a little
game we call plead the fifth
I will give you three questions and you
know the drill you can plead the fifth
to only one all right you ready Andy
Cohen what's the most boring Housewives
franchise in your opinion
none of them I mean lead the political
just when you start to think of
franchises boring something crazy
happened after married till yeah
Anderson Cooper yeah Sarah Jessica
Parker okay Oprah no I'll marry SJ shag
Anderson and kill Oprah Wow maybe I'll
shank Oprah so I could say that I did
that which one of your celebrity friends
smokes the best weed oh um oh wow that's
a good question uh you know I took like
a big heavy Willie no song hey Tom which
one my serenity
ah judge Donnelly the Manatee off yeah
everyone I'm thinking of it's like
indeed jiminy pot yes they all [ __ ]
take my weed I'm the guy that gets all
the pot Andy you made it through you
might have come in here with little
trepidation but look at you now do my
lips look pink to you looking good
yes on fire but I wouldn't be able to
tell this camera this camera or this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life love connection
Fox radio Andy Sirius XM superficial in
paperback watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen Sunday through Thursday then
and now with Andy Cohen Wednesday's on
Bravo
the Real Housewives of everywhere
Anderson Cooper and Andy Cohen keep
talking shallow tails go to AC to live
for ticket information I think that's
all my plug
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey better than you thought it would be
no it was actually worse because I
didn't think about it too much but it
actually might Alfred hey what's going
on hot ones fans if you liked the video
maybe meet us halfway throw us a
subscribe if you didn't like the video
don't subscribe I don't want you I don't
want you in the tent but if you like the
video subscribe thank you very much I
appreciate you I love you more than a
friend